[Music]
um
has been defeated
yes so we uh we defeated the little
mermaid
very beautiful mermaid very jealous um
and now we're off
to see uh mr heisenberg
uh himself
is there anything else that i can do
there before i go though is there
anything that i've
missed uh is the only thing that i i
want to get
the the recipe that makes me go faster
but i have no
bloody clue where fish are on this map
okay so we can draw the strawbridge and
we can go over here
uh is it this yeah
why is a boat i feel like i'm not
supposed to be here yet
am i supposed to be here yet
i feel like i'm jumping the gun with
this one
i've got so much stuff i wish i could
buy more space
it's my bloody fish and meat it's just
in the way
i have four fish
i have so much fish but i just need like
a special fish
i think it'll look good it's got a
special fish
uh should i get another one of them
as for shotgun yes
um
let's just get in the boat
i'm on a boat
i don't know where i'm going
i found my destination
what the hell where
am i wait
what have i been here before map
lady dimitrisk
a letter what what what what
no not a key
the crank
[Music]
says this is where i killed lady d yes
this is definitely where i killed her in
it
in it i remember
i remember you i remember this place
oh memories beautiful
right
okay so don't care about all this
but there was a where was that chesty
chest
over here can i go in here
okay
[Music]
uh
do i need to light the things again can
i hit it with my head again
no
ye yeah
no he's still
[ __ ]
feel the force
okay that was all right
anything in here
bad idea
you were kidding me with a oh no it's a
sword i thought i
thought it was a hammer for some weird
reason right
no [ __ ] way are you kidding me
can i close the door again i don't like
this
they keep [ __ ] coming
oh god jesus
i feel like i'm just gonna waste all my
ammo
medium rare regardless are you on fire
no no no no no no no no no no no
where'd she go
come here come here flaming zombie
set fire to this thing please
please yes what a wonderful helpful one
you are
turn around quickly
i got the statue this is fun
that's a mammal
i can't believe fire doesn't hurt you
are you gonna die
[Applause]
see ya
bye
hi well that was fun
that was that was nice i enjoyed that
good little fun games okay now let's get
back to doing what we're supposed to be
doing
i think that's all of the things
all of the extra surprise stuffs
oh no there's some stuff over here but
uh yeah we're gonna go there when we
open the locked door
so let's get back in the boat
apparently i was mean to the zombie but
you know he was trying to kill me
or she or they definitely trying to kill
me so
i think i'm within my rights to be
honest self-defense and all that
can i go down
louis texas streaming in
oh icon
where we ended up this time
near the ceremony site
this is the way to the ceremony because
if so i don't need to be here yet
uh
oh hey chris was here um dna sequencing
complete
99.95 percent match to dolby
mutamicite due to me seat
the deviation of 0.05 can presumably be
attributed to the artificial
changes by humans which means this is
probably the source
rather is investigation into how the
connections
manage to find and extract the moulds is
needed the fungal colony is spread out
under the entire village
when you take the baker incident into
account the hosts of the
mutami seat are part of a network
of consciousnesses if that network is
linked to here then we could assume this
organism here is do
is data storage what the frick
what the frick if this if that's the
case
then what data is miranda after
okay what the hell weird ass
got a nice coin though i don't know how
i'm managing to carry all this i'm
basically out
of space everywhere
nice
what gun this one
hell yeah thanks chris
dna written in assembly code
it's like i'd love how ethan still has
time to go on both adventures
yes same i mean we all need a little bit
of uh a little bit me time you know
ethan's ethan's getting his even though
this place is a little bit creepy so
we're gonna run out of here and hope
that nothing happens
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
what's the way out
i knew it i knew it
no way i'm staying in there hell no
although i kind of want to see what
actually happened but i'm not going to
because
ammo needs to be reserved
is there anything down here
you're my special trout that i needed
your special trout yes
why is ui confusing me
sweet
okay back to
the juke yeah that's his name
naturally
duke's kitchen
thank you now to cook
here it is please join me oh
yes so
i wouldn't mind having that again now
let's get rid of some of this meat if we
can
um i guess we could have this
yeah why the hell not so let's store
all of this and then we'll just need one
fish
we can keep an eye out for that and then
should i put this anywhere health
increases
fine let's get rid of this thank you
food is life
i can hardly wait for the next
ingredients
there we've also freed up some space so
this is good
i'm so glad we found that fish
here we go
good luck no can i go up here
look like we could actually go up here
but i am
okay let's go the obvious way and then
we'll check up here
oh jesus christ you're alive it's alive
well i see footprints
oh thank you very nice
he's scared me no lucky
oh god
oh [ __ ] off you know [ __ ] bag
impressive oh [ __ ] [ __ ] balls
no not my knife not my knife
oh god
oh that was that was super close
ah i need to get more of this
i do have scrap maybe i can make some
more
i see you i do
i can hear more but i can't see any but
i know they're there
they sound really close but i know
they're not
where are you
is that one yes
definitely
oh god here we go see who comes get
ready
here he comes
scrap oh yes please
[Music]
i know i'm supposed to use them in like
a gameplay sense has anyone actually
used them for gameplay
good day
yeah feel the wrath
mama
what other guns have i got
oh yeah i've got my wolf spain
but i've only got three ammo for that so
i'll wait
can i make any more ammo
will be handy right now
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] everywhere
yes please thank you please yes
no i'll get you no you can meet me
i get you
good
can i get up this rock because i killed
a thing up there and i might
something might be up there for me
no oh okay fine
can i jump
all right ethan can't jump
unless he's in a cutscene and it's all
very dramatic
damn look at all these what are they
crows
i don't trust the um where's that hair
i don't trust the rooftops where the
bloody is that you
don't even know where you were supposed
to be but i will take you
okay there are boxes and red barrels
here which is very nice
appreciate a nice red barrel
why though
because there's nothing for me to fight
in here
yet
dead people
dear people
[Music]
[Applause]
[ __ ] you [ __ ] oh crap
[Music]
i keep missing all right
okay okay okay okay okay okay now it's
time for my
my wolf's been baby
baby baby baby baby
baby all right come to me come to mama
come to mama come to my cousin mama
are we done we done here for now
for now yes
anyone drop anything down there hello do
i need to come back down
i love picking up stuff
anyone drop anything down here okay oh
yes
okay that'll do i'm happy with that
let's uh make some more ammo then so
what kind of uh
magnum rounds can we make magnum rounds
oh we need to take some
take some help uh i don't think we can
make magnum rounds which is a shame
we've only got two of those left so
hopefully we'll find
find some more
uh
um
cool
get
money i don't want money
i want ammunition
why don't i get this door open
i gotta go up that ladder oh shotgun
i'll take that
ah there's going to be some more hordes
out there
well there's a red barrel down here so
i'll just keep that oh and one over
there so i will keep that in mind
while i do this
tell you what with all this happening i
am so glad that i got that extra
ammunition
[ __ ] you [ __ ] [ __ ] you [ __ ]
ah
oh [ __ ] sake
i love my shotgun
where are you
are you [ __ ] kidding me okay you know
what i think i just have to [ __ ] go
for it don't i
all right let's do this but i gotta pick
up all the stuff
did i pick up that that lovely scout oh
my god oh my god they're everywhere
they're everywhere they're everywhere oh
my god oh my god just run
run
[ __ ] go for it [ __ ] go for it
[ __ ] go for it and then turn around
and then use your shotgun and then
boom [ __ ] where are they boom
boom
oh my god oh my god
no no no no no no i'm cornered this is
no fun this is not bad this is my friend
okay what do i do now pick everything up
this is what i do this is what i do
pick everything up pick up your finger
go pick everything up
pick everything up pick everything up
truck stand up
i can't aim at you i can't aim at you
oh gosh he just went by the wall that
was brilliant
oh that was brilliant you just head back
at the wall oh
okay that
was intense but we managed to
scrape through barely
ah
thank you thank
probably nothing you around here
right so did i get that skull that i
wanted oh
thank you
did i get the skull up here yeah i must
have done
okay then good to go
easy peasy piddle and piss
i should've already used this one but i
don't have any ammo for it or
i can oh hahaha
oh pipe bomb thank you very much
let's use this i mean do both
okay the same
yeah i am really stocked up uh
i guess because i did hear that from
here it's less scary and more fighty
so uh we'll see how we do
oh cool see the little birds out there
beautiful birds
because shoots them down
oh where am i going i'm supposed to go
down here
red barrel over here
this must be their den oh well done
ethan
don't just talk out loud about that this
must be their dan
i have a ride
where the hell are they i hate these
things
[Music]
[Applause]
don't get back up you little [ __ ] tits
oh god you did
no i need to shoot the barrels i need to
shoot the barrels
i need to shoot their [ __ ] barrels
that didn't even do anything today
go
oh okay we found a strategy
hello come to mama she's a present for
you
all of you oh yeah
oh god
i didn't mean to do that to your brother
why are you all men actually
was it like heisenberg got the men and
then uh lady oh [ __ ] i didn't mean to do
that lady dimitris got all the ladies or
the ladders
oh the cigar ladders oh this thing got
ladders
oh the single ladders all the single
ladders
oh she [ __ ] i'm not going to waste
this on you
oh [ __ ] yeah well uh this changes
everything
i got a bit of coffee there i shouldn't
have slashed you
there's more
i was so determined to hit the red
barrel and
i didn't i was like so into it i just
didn't time it so like nothing actually
happened when i
this is my safe zone
it definitely wasn't intended for me to
be able to use this staircase like this
but i'm not
the bud
hello anyone else want a piece of me
oh yes you do okay okay okay okay
okay wait hold up i've got a present for
you
turn around
i don't know how that didn't just blow
me up
ethan is invincible to my
explosions
but not too rebel so i must be careful
are they just never ending
never ending
[ __ ] you never ever
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
why am i like this shut up all right
big i said bye-bye
oh my god yeah you're not a big guy
you're not the one i should be fearing
oh i get so many skulls and
did i kill a big guy
when did i kill big guy did i think was
that bigger
of course he wasn't so scary didn't do
it
isn't it
okay
um
yeah i'm good
oh hello he's missing a groin wait yeah
wait
if someone was to wear this piece of
armor also
would have to do just kick him in the
balls
or twist his thumbs but you know
anyway i guess he would probably wear a
plate in his
pants i don't i don't know anyway
i just found that amusing
anything new probably not i can see
inside it
oh
cow's milk
you see down here i can't see you think
this too small
tiny man
so the better shotgun is this one isn't
it even though i've upgraded that one i
don't know
i don't know uh let's just try
and i there's no point using this one
because
a small semi-automatic so let's try
shortcutting this one instead
great [ __ ] great barking
great
oh no
wait i see you
no i have to
where am i going this way i can't see
anything i don't like this
i haven't saved my game oh
oh that's cool i like this
well that explains all the hanging
corpses
okay let's just keep moving
oh [ __ ] oh god
hopefully they don't see me
i got a mine
the king's orders finally arrived
withdraw
it is most vexing that we must abandon
the border stronghold to those heretics
if i had but a little more time i know i
might be able to turn the tides of this
battle
nay i should not put on airs it is my
curiosity that ties me to this place
there are a number of ruins in the
vicinity which the locals say are very
ancient
the ceremony sites with four giant
statues the cave with murals carved on
the walls
the stone plinth they call the giants
chalice
where did the people who built them come
from where do they go
it airs me that we must abandon this
place without knowing
well i bet you're dead now so maybe you
regret that
typewriter yay that's the side i like to
see
okay so at least we've done that still
just holding my mind because
it's to come in handy i know
because now we know that ethan is immune
to minds
what a wonderful man oh it's
it's quiet it's too quiet
it's getting shivers
yep welcome knew it
that's not good
where are you gonna come from oh my god
ah for foxy foxy
kill me
come here please no
what are you doing get back here
oh [ __ ] say katherine
okay um
put it back down okay
oh get the [ __ ]
land on my
my thingamajigger name
yes yes
how how how how how
how
hold up i want to make some more bums
we have flashbang maybe we could use a
fancy gun
um
[Music]
um
yeah let's use a fancy gun
foreign
oh [ __ ] sake you little [ __ ]
oh god nothing wait wait i don't know
what i'm doing
oh god please leave me alone i'm scared
okay now what
[Music]
ah
oh lta
oh god hurry the [ __ ] up
i need to pick up that pipe on bob's too
scared
um
[Music]
i sound like a witch i'm so scared i
don't know
okay okay okay i need to pick up some
shades
i need explosions i need explosions in
my life i need explosions
i think i picked something up
yes beautiful love you
oh [ __ ] off you know [ __ ] bag i'm
getting
so angry how
dare it do that to me right
ah jesus oh i could have just got some
explosives then hmm
okay
uh what should i use i got i got one
more pipeline
well or if i use it in conjunction
oh [ __ ] up here crap right and now
please say that did something
[Music]
what's this oh my god i have magnum ammo
[ __ ] here now i didn't even
oh
don't like this
oh [ __ ] off you little [ __ ] bag
how many times have i said that today
all right um
what was my plan again oh yeah
[Music]
[Music]
i should have used this gun earlier
and die
oh yeah
[Music]
[Music]
he thought i was gonna die bess up i
know you thought i was gonna die
and i didn't
no shotgun left that side
thanks drinks a lot wow wow well done
calling me impressed
what was uh what was your um wait was
this your bet rexella
and if so what was your bet so basically
for anyone who's not in the know
rexalite had a bet um and
they told me they had a bet and it was
for this episode
and if i proved them wrong or if their
bet was right i don't know which one was
which but
they would um they would give me
five pounds thank you for that
i appreciate that but yeah what was it
what was the bet
i want to know what it was was it that i
wouldn't die
or was it that i would run out of ammo
my bet was having any health left after
this place
i can see why it's very easy to
to become trapped like in one of these
corners especially
with the little ones running around as
well but luckily i had some explosives
and i had more magnum rounds than i than
i thought i did so
i'm quite lucky actually
oh thanks for sticking around james
oh my god
i feel so tired now
i think i just expended so much energy
through that fight
damn okay uh
wait excuse me oh i thought this game
just did a
evil within on me where you turn around
and everything's different
anything amazing
oh my tv
oh cool
that was weird did i just get like a
flashback
you're the real deal ethan well done
quit hiding [ __ ] i'm not letting you
get out of this
cool your jets just a little bit more
and you're all wrapped up i'll lend you
a hand
so in exchange in exchange what
first of all come to me put all the
flasks in the altar
and i'm sure you'll figure the rest out
see you
ethan god damn it
why does he want me to put rose in
the altar because i thought that's what
they were fighting against i don't get
it
i'm actually really confused i thought
he was going i thought heisenberg was
going to be the boss not
that axe well it wasn't
a hammer wielding giant thing
unless he's now
good liamo's plate a good glimmer
oh my boat right wait are there any
fish do i need more fish no i don't i
found the fish
googly eyed
huh ladder or
[Music]
let's check the ladder first i'm sure we
can come back down
oh hell yeah
okay so we found this i'm just gonna
check
thank you
photo of the fan a phantom fish
keep finding these photos and then um
jacob uh due to edits these videos he he
told me that the last one i picked up
i'd already found so
i'll check out this one then see if i
found that
kado implantation notes
knee high m 21 male
silversmith scars from pneumonia
low affinity cato failed to grow body
transformation dropping
cognition another liking sent to the
pastor
so all the lycans are people from the
village that's sad i'm sorry
just straight up killed a 21 year old
female bernadette sorry bernadette
um uh als
alcina 44 female noble descendant
not from the village hereditary blood
disease
very high affinity no loss of cognition
obituary up arbitrarily
able to control body transformation
transformation
applied cognition control procedure
central observation
so so
this was like a proper werewolf then
because she could
choose when the body transformation
happened
that's pretty cool sent for observation
so where is she then
oh she's supposed to be the big big
baddie that i just killed
annoying
uh
okay goodbye
oh elsina is lady dimitrisk okay fair
enough
oh of course because she turned into
like a beast
and then she was able to control it yeah
that makes sense
ah okay back out in the open
so
what what
i'm gonna save in here
i was gonna save back with the duke but
i don't think so anymore
i think i'll save right now
okay everything seems
okay oh good
okay hello it's my greatest pleasure to
see you return alive
yeah only because i could welcome you
okay so i have this big crystal
and i have this crystal skull
i have this perfect crystal
i don't know how to do that i have this
should i just sell that i feel like i'm
never going to find the final piece
i'll wait just in case
emos googly almost googly almost
uh one of the four founders
no no i'm more than happy to purchase it
thank you um you know what
i think this is a good place to stop
i don't know or should we just put it in
should we put it in see what happens yes
[Music]
please
what
[Music]
what's beautiful saying
[Music]
and i stream every thursday 8
30 pm bst so
yeah i will see you next thursday
you